[Music]
[Applause]
hold your body
[Music]
barracuda
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome him to the stage
[Music]
all right so he is the uh
foreign
[Music]
developments is actually going
hello
probably the Creator the devs really
want to just release and show you guys
what exactly what we have in uh
so hopefully we this excitement could be
passed
which title are you going to introduce
so first we're gonna do your announce it
giving you more information about the
one that's going to be releasing first
yeah like a dragon a man who erased the
name here's the trailer
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
because
actually this video was recorded
yesterday so this is the newest info
exactly exactly so let's go ahead and
show the uh the two styles of the battle
actions so first one video Let's Go
awesome
oh my God
[Music]
so this video showed the audio style the
Yakuza style
usually
is the actual uh tattoo that's shown
back so that's why we call it audio
style aka the Yakuza Style
[Music]
let's go ahead and show that video right
now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this game
foreign
it looks very interesting with all the
new gadgets too so the one thing that we
actually have one focused and important
in mind in the Yakuza series is because
we're fighting it takes place in a city
so we're fighting in the city so you
want to use like anything that's around
in the city oh bicycles signs and be
able to uniquely use those in different
situations and that's why that in recent
series like all the other series
but now you can use the wire and bring
those signs or objects
hopefully the battles like strategy has
improved slash changed updated with this
uh agent style as well so hopefully you
will uh enjoy this Style
thank you very much for explaining a lot
about the Battle actions
foreign
[Music]
so that's why we wanted to take
I think a lot of fans are very familiar
with uh
[Music]
and also in the video that was shown
earlier
yeah sorry if we're talking about all
the previous series
probably some people who there are some
people who haven't played yet so
apologies
like
a Osaka Castle kind of style
is this
well something that's really similar to
that
foreign
a little bit about the character who was
sitting on the top of the tower oh yeah
it was in the trailers too
but
it seems like a lot of people
it seems like they really want to show
up and come upstairs
please
welcome him onto the stage
thank you
I love your style uh
we have motomiya yes
voicing that character it's subsidiary
[Music]
first summer Rica
for all the guests
foreign
[Music]
welcome
everybody
[Music]
so it has been seven years
sex and there was going to be another
story about Kiryu uh so what did you
feel about that
like I feel like every question
I always feel like this is gonna be my
last time to play Kiryu and especially
finished Yakuza six that was like the
end
but I really love the characters
happy
[Music]
really
uh happy or interested
[Music]
different aged characters
would you tell us a little bit about how
you felt about uh well you actually got
the offer first and also about your
characters
if you say the Yakuza series it's like
one of the Legendary game series
I really always wanted to be in it for
sure but then I was first contacted
do I really have the right to join like
voice like am I even ready
and I actually asked to like my fancy
like should I really take the offer
[Music]
how do you how do you feel and what do
you think about you like a dragon Series
so yeah have made the show called Nihon
toitsu for 10 years
we did a lot of collaboration with like
different places
[Music]
or games that's been a long time and
there's always like someone
they actually have like a heart
and we have like uh
developers had like so much love towards
this is
I I actually realized like each person
had puts their heart and soul in this
game so it felt like working with them
so when we
how they do their work
anyway
foreign
usually
[Music]
more intellectual than eccentric usually
he's Whispering something into his ears
so like usually I he play out all these
crazy eccentric characters in those
shows but you know that you can talk oh
actually
so yeah most of the work that uh it's
usually people who goes wild crazy so
this time around
like if I to be honest
I have so much lines
did you think when you actually uh read
the the script first
when I first got the offer it was like
really the Yakuza series
like I usually do a lot of the actions
first I thought you I was offered as a
motion motion actor but then I was like
then I was told like oh you're the voice
I was like oh oh thank goodness thank
goodness
how was it recording
I was like yeah it was it was pretty
smooth
because like uh so the characters they
will be acting is using the Kansai
dialect but you guys are not from
so that's why
I feel like they might have a little bit
of struggling while acting does but they
were doing great
are you guys actually used to speaking
Kansai dialects oh we're not
foreign
so all the characters in in the shows
are talking in Kansai dialect
yeah so I'm really glad that they were
able to do the uh pull out
so now we want to ask
so if I'm not wrong
um I think you applied for this Cabaret
audition for this game
is it correct
coconut cities of places actually during
during covid I I I've heard played the
Yakuza series for the first time and
actually played Yakuza like a dragon at
first but then when I first played I
started
I started playing the Yakuza series and
then all since then I only talk about
the yogsa series on the radio or TV
shows I felt like the yogsa series has
opened up a different world to me
and when I heard about the Cabaret
audition I was like I really want to be
in it I really want to be in the games
so that's why I applied for the uh the
Cabaret auditions
yes we did get that get the application
application
the character that we actually uh asked
we got to do we started writing a
scripts
and we actually were having her image
when she was with this character and
then we saw her application
that's why before we accept those uh
auditions we sent an offer first
and also because it was like at the end
of the year so it was hard
so that's why when during audition we
asked we could say like hey do you does
your agency know about you're here and
she's like yeah no no no I'm here all
alone by myself so no matter what my
agency says I want to play this part
that's what she said at the audition but
then we already had gave an offer to her
agency about this character so we wanted
to tell her that during the audition
first but then I guess
but the grand prize Grand Prix of this
Edition will be on like a dragon
infinite
and she's like what about me then am I
gonna show up in like a drag like a
dragon infinite World and she's like no
like see I wanted to be in uh yeah like
a dragon if in a wealth too but I'm
actually really honored to be able to be
a part of this game
they're like what what do you mean raw
audition right Cabaret audition so in
Japanese they were saying
which means live action uh Cabaret
audition so you won't be in there as a
3D character but actually as a live
action video as a cabaret audition as a
cabaret in the game
oh
from all around and then actually told
saying if you keep on saying that it
might be a bad effect to actually be
offered this role so after hearing that
was like oh maybe I shouldn't be too
eager to be wanting to be in the yeah so
you love this series so much and now
you're in it so how's your opinions
towards the game change
so I'm just completely like a pure fan
being in
the game like I would just be like oh
this is how you
um do this game oh this is how you
actually get me and the game and just
being seeing all these uh things feels
everything was so new to me and I'm just
super just excited and happy
so like it's actually everybody has like
the same reaction like the moment they
all come into the developer room and
like and everybody has like similar
reaction the studio you're just great
it's just amazing it's like as a small I
I played Kung Fu
when I was a kid and just you know
played a game back in the kid and just
seeing
seeing like the game uh developing world
that I loved as a kid and just seeing
the studio like oh this is
the place that the Magics are made and
just kind of really surprised so they
were very surprised about how many
cameras they actually had in the studio
they had like 50 and it's like yeah
that's uh we record your body from all
around to make the computer Graphics do
you have a 3D avatar first and also the
thickness of the script
they printed for the papers
is the script is just so big and I
couldn't even put it in the bag and I
felt like just carrying it might destroy
my shoulders
and I actually did not so all the
people's scripts are written in this
whole script but I didn't want to read
everybody else's script because I want
to enjoy the game purely like as an
actor probably I should
look at all the other people's lives as
a fan I was like don't I don't wanna I
don't wanna see I don't want to see it's
like no spoilers please
try to tell her what happened
[Music]
was actually trying to not to hear he
was like no no no no no no no no please
please I'm trying to enjoy the game like
I'm trying to lose like avoid any kind
of spoilers
and also at the end of the video
another person unfortunately he could
not come to the event today but we got
the video message from him so please
check it out
questions
foreign
[Music]
guided
foreign
[Music]
now in the gameplay
the third has has
you be able to tell us whether he is the
enemy or the Dallas
if you look at it obviously it looked
like an enemy didn't it all right
he was like Hey like he completely asked
the name and he said I don't have a name
you won't go off continuing saying then
let's go have a drink right so that
obviously in the trailer it was like an
enemy but
yeah
but I can't give you any other details
hopefully uh you guys can kind of get
the photo yeah
would you tell us the release date for
this the man who erased the name his
name
this game's release date is going to be
2023 November 9th right pre-order has
already started so please
thank you very much to all the guests
would you give us some message to your
family uh this time around okay it was
my first time actually working at a
voicing a game character
it's like being able to see a little bit
behind the scenes of game development
and seeing like oh this game was made
like so many people so many new
technologies
I was so surprised
crazy the game development was well
and now then this is going to be a new
game
I feel like this is like one of the best
games
like I I like I don't I can't see
exactly how this game would be uh uh
released so hopefully I can enjoy the
game with you guys as well so I would
love to play the game when it's released
as well thank you
thank you very much
so after I read the script
and recorded in the studio
when I was like seeing how it was it was
way bigger than I expected like it was
went over and Beyond so please look
forward to it thank you very much
[Applause]
could you give some message to your fans
so the guidance
so it seems like the guidance is a story
that we connect from six seven and eight
uh six like a dragon infinite wealth so
I'm glad that I was part of that too and
maybe
series some people might be uh really
angry at me saying like you just came in
from like uh seven how dare you you Noob
but I
feel like I was able to uh I was able to
act out the character as a player myself
so please please you might hate me but
please
[Music]
thank you very much
that was a joke right yes
it must be a joke thank you very much
thank you very much
has like a gag of like you can hate me
but do not hate this yeah so she was
like please you can hate me but do
nothing
we have another guests
please in
like a dragon infinite wealth let's
welcome him to the stage
all right
[Music]
here we go
thank you very much
yes I will be playing Ichiban from like
a dragon infinite wealth nice to meet
y'all
so now we have double protagonists for
like a dragon infinite World today here
on stage
[Music]
the video that we just released last
week let's go ahead and check it out
foreign
[Music]
cocoa
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
oh
starts up dude yes
huh
[Music]
yeah
was totally naked in the trailer and
also he's at the speech in a foreign
[Music]
so pretty much we wanted to kind of
showcase uh you know that from going
back up again I guess he's always like
that he'll start out kind of something
like that all the time just kind of
throw it thrown out like completely butt
naked but you cannot tell us where this
is right is it a foreign country yeah
it's just kind of foreign country but
yes foreign country
that's actually that wasn't like a
promotional video that was just made to
Showcase but no that that's literally in
the game it's just a cut from uh you're
literally a king game footage that would
be shown in game two
yes
I don't know how he's gonna end up on
the beach he's completely naked yeah
it's true like you would you can't
expect but yeah maybe that's why
he's like yeah it's like a promotional
video that the tell so it's a
promotional video so people can't guess
what's gonna happen but it was a great
video I was like when I saw it I was
like that's great it was like it's
really interesting how they were able to
hide his jungle
like recently there was like a pretty
popular person in Japan that was like
that was popular of not showing right
completely naked so people thought like
oh we jumped in on the occasion but no
no it was just the timing wise
yes
he was like yeah Sega is insane huh
that's right
you you had some kind of sexy voice
showing up uh in this video I don't know
about sex
when I recorded this uh voice I was
wearing clothes so do not worry that I
was not but naked I recorded but he's
like of course
but this scene we did not record the
audio uh matching the video but we just
recorded the audio first and then we
added
you did such a great job you really did
a great job picking up the nuances the
situation
so yeah I did my best so hopefully you
all would sure
like infinite wealth is after like a
dragon
so that's why so probably
[Music]
you wanted to come
that's in the game and we want to kind
of show you guys that now
foreign
[Music]
girl
um
so this is the newest trailer right
there were some keywords in the trailer
in the conversation
so there was something about sayako
there's a relationship going on maybe
with hiker like a proposing a broken
heart yes that's right
foreign
[Music]
if you guessed that main story is about
love story no way
we were able to kind of show that like
you know the two main characters the
main protagonist would kind of have a
conversation like this in game
being able to see these two main
characters like side by side that's like
the strong aspect fuel protagonists
that's just not like a service shot of
them just being together but it's like
one of the main aspects of the game
right it's like there are like
differences
to get to this place there's a lot of
thing has happened too so you know
just look at the scene and use this as
pretty much some nutrients for
satisfying your itch of the new yeah
oh that video of the hermit
crabs the beach scene and this uh this
scene and just like well those two
scenes are completely two different uh
season I don't know if you guys could
get that uh Yakuza series itch by just
watching those two videos
but the main story is uh it has a grand
epic story
that's like oh so in the guidance maybe
we might be able to get more information
why he they were able to conversate like
this and he's like oh maybe it could be
but also like in the actual game you'll
be able to in infinite wealth you'll be
able to get more information of why they
were able to kind of have their
relationships
oh so this is the release date for both
titles uh yes on the left is the the man
who erased its name it's gonna be
released on November 9th 2023 and also
like a dragon 8 Infinity wealth will be
early 2024.
please look forward to these two games
please look forward to both of the
titles
I guess we gotta wrap it up
so would you give some comments and
messages to your fans
people who's watching rgg Summit thank
you very much thank you very much
in like a dragon infinite wealth
I look forward to this game thank you
very much
[Music]
like completely it's out of uh what you
can expect it's beyond imagination yes
you'll be like oh that's how it leads up
to the story there's like so many
situations where like oh that's how it
goes
so you will be really uh surprised but
you'll enjoy and also the guidance a man
who erased his name the story is
incredible
[Music]
so like it's a completely different
character from their show so please if
you're a fan of them please enjoy their
different uh characters that will be
acting other than the toys
please be excited for the game thank you
very much
please give some messages
[Music]
thank you very much for today thank you
all for coming and watching
hopefully you guys enjoyed this show or
the summit first
okay
[Music]
so I'm glad that people started uh
actually accepting the name change
and also for people who uh accepted as
another character with alongside
and now that I'm like okay here as a
producer here General producer of this
whole uh show uh the game I like want to
present what the fans want and I feel
like I have made a great game that the
fans would want but I would want to like
why I want to share more uh information
about the game details uh we can't give
you guys a little detail but I actually
got this a little uh
we have rgg Summit fall 2023 to show you
more uh information about these two
games
so it's pretty much like it says fall
right so it's pretty much like the same
as last year she's like so is it okay to
assume that it's gonna be in September
and she's like yeah maybe pretty much
we'll probably have more info by them
right yeah of course yeah of course but
so we'll give you more information about
yeah because uh infinite wealth uh like
a dragon infinite wealth yes
thank you very much
so I guess this is
summer 2023. thank you all for watching
and also thank you very much
and to everybody over here
thank you very much
please look forward to upcoming titles
and upcoming info from rgg Studio thank
you very much everyone thank you and
thank you all uh hopefully you all
enjoyed our translation thank you very
much thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you